STEWART BRAND: So here's another in a sense national policy question from Kevin Kelly: can we
learn anything about reforming capitalism from China?
MARIANA MAZZUCATO: My previous book was called The Entrepreneurial State. And when I think
of China, I think of the 'Adaptive State.'
China, really interestingly I think, is
learning from the US in a moment that
the US. is unlearning from itself.
It struck me that the first thing Trump did when he came into office was
actually attacked particular public
organizations: ARPA-E and PBS. And what
China's been doing—and I think
there's a question or whether it's gonna
be successful or not—is forming
actually quite active investor
innovative public organizations. But
they're huge. They're huge. It's not a
decentralized network of public
organizations across the whole
innovation chain, as we had in the US. So
the Chinese Development Bank is a
massive financial institution which has
provided loans up to nine billion for
many of its companies, including Huawei. Huawei wouldn't exist without the
Chinese Development Bank. By the way,
Huawei, which is on the news a lot, is a
cooperative. Can you believe that?
In Dalian, I met—they had a tea
ceremony in Dalian, China because the
World Economic Forum has a youth
component that meets and Dalian—and
Huawei executives asked me and three
other economists—this was back in, I
think, 2013—to meet with them to say what should we do about the US? It was very
strange, thinking about what's
happening now. And we were like, 'What do you mean?' They were like,
'Well yeah, it's really hard in the US,
we're not really penetrating the
market.' And my advice was: 'Tell them you're a cooperative.' I mean just in terms of
getting...what I think is interesting in China is there's a lot of
variety; there's not one model. There's
lots of different types of organizations,
hence the Huawei example. It's a
cooperative. There's state-owned
companies, there's companies that are
actually going more towards—slowly I
think—a more market-driven and
anglo-saxon model, almost. But there's
variety there. There's also much more
meritocracy
in terms of who works in governments than we have in many
countries. In the UK there's very little
meritocracy in terms of who
actually rises up in government. There's
lots of experiments actually at the
community level but it also has problems of
democracy. So it's not a cut and paste model from
communist versus capitalist. But
how it evolves, the degree to which there
is engagement...for example,
they're spending 1.7 trillion on
greening their economy, coming back to
the Green missions. And this is out of
urgency. And it's really
interesting how also in the US,. big
things happen when there is urgency, when there's war. And if you've seen
also the documentary on the Roosevelts,
it's fantastic. When there was urgency,
big things happen in the US. And so the
degree to which this urgency creates
—because of pollution—is creating both
a very positive change—so 1.7 trillion
on greening the economy including energy-friendly technologies, not just renewable
energy—but also that rush to
create and invest and not focus on
really rebalancing the whole economy, for
example, around consumption and services
is is causing the economy to be
unbalanced.